The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
VICTOR COSTAN: So I'm excited
about today's recitation,
because if I do this
right and you guys get it,
then I can mess up every
other recitation after it.
And you'll still get
the gist of 6.006.
So all I have to do
is get this working.
So most of the time
in the real world
you're probably not going to be
coming up with new algorithms
to do something, but rather
you'll have some code
and you want to make it faster.
And the first step
in making it faster
is you realize, how
does it do right now?
How does it run, which lines
are slow, which lines are fast,
and where you can
make improvements.
So in lecture we talked
about the Python Cost Model
which is what you use
to look at the code
and figure out how much
time it takes to run.
And we talked about
document distance,
which is a problem
that we'll use
to practice our analysis skills.
And this entire
recitation is all
about looking at versions
of document distance
and analyzing them.
So that's what we'll
do, look at Python code,
look at Python code,
look at Python code.
So you better have handouts,
because I can't project.
OK, how many people remember
the document distance problem?
You guys said you went
to lecture, right?
OK, so very, very fast,
document distance.
I have two documents.
The fox is in the hat.
And the fox is outside.
Document 1, document 2.
What's the first
thing I want to do?
So there are three operations
that Eric mentioned in lecture.
Operation one,
take each document,
break it up into words.
Right?
This is a string.
When I read it, then it becomes
word one, word two, word three,
word four, so on and so forth.
Operation two, build
document vectors
out of the two documents.
So the documents are D1 and D2.
A document vector
is basically a list
of the words in the documents
with a count of how many times
each word appears
in the document.
So let's build a document
vector for document one.
I'm not going to
write it formally,
so can anyone tell me
what it should look like,
and I'll sort of write
it down as a list.
So for all the words here,
I want to list the words
and how many times they show up.
Somebody, please.
AUDIENCE: The is in there twice?
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
The, twice.
AUDIENCE: Fox, once.
VICTOR COSTAN: One.
AUDIENCE: Is, once.
VICTOR COSTAN: Is, one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] in once.
VICTOR COSTAN: In, one.
AUDIENCE: Hat once.
VICTOR COSTAN: Awesome.
Thank you very much.
Second one.
Another volunteer.
Yes, go for it.
AUDIENCE: The, once.
VICTOR COSTAN: The, one.
AUDIENCE: Fox, once.
VICTOR COSTAN: Fox, one
AUDIENCE: Is, one.
VICTOR COSTAN: Is, one.
AUDIENCE: Outside, one.
VICTOR COSTAN: Outside, one.
OK, so this is a
document vector.
Notice two small details.
Here, they is capitalized,
here it's not,
and yet I bundle them together.
I know my grammar,
so I put periods
at the end of the
sentences, and yet they
don't show up anywhere here.
So we got rid of
the punctuation,
and we made all words lowercase.
These are details,
but they are details
that you'll see in
the code, so if you're
wondering why, this is why.
So step one, read the document,
make it a list of words.
Step two, compute
the document vector.
Step three, take the
two document vectors,
and compute the angle.
What is the angle of
two document vectors?
Big ugly math formula.
The only thing that's relevant
is that it takes these vectors
and computes an inner product.
So if we look at the code for
angle vector, or vector angle,
you'll see that because
numerator denominator lines two
and three, it calls
inner product three times
and then it does
some math with it.
We don't care about the math.
We assume the math is order one.
We only care about
inner product.
How does inner product work?
Can anyone help me compute the
inner product for these guys?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It's like
the dot product?
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: So, if we take the
vectors and you multiply them,
like, you're adding to
the components, right?
Because they're so thick--
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, this
is too complicated, then.
I'm seriously
depressed, so give me
some clear instructions
step by step.
AUDIENCE: Like,
I know you divide
by the length of
each of the vectors--
VICTOR COSTAN: Let's
not worry about that.
I have these vectors, and
I want an inner product.
I don't care about the angle,
just the inner product.
AUDIENCE: OK, well do 2
times 1 for the right.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
So I take the here,
shows up twice.
I take the here, shows up once.
2 times 1, right?
AUDIENCE: Mhm.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
And then?
AUDIENCE: I would
do the same for fox.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, fox shows up
here once, shows up here once,
so what I do?
AUDIENCE: 1 times 1.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: And do
the same for is.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: And in should be 0.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] in.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: And then
outside would also be 0,
and hat would also be 0.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
So it turns out you don't
have to go through both lists.
It's sufficient to go
through one of the vectors
and look up the words
in the other vector.
Because if the words don't
show up in any of the vectors,
their contribution
is going to be 0.
So my algorithm is go
through each of the elements
here, look up each of the words
there, look up at the word
here.
And if there's a
word here and here,
take out the number of times
it shows up in each document,
multiply them, and
then add everything up.
So this is inner product.
Everything else is good if
you're writing a search engine
or if you're using the
scenario application,
but we're not really
concerned with it.
OK, so now we have
the three steps,
read the document,
break it up into words,
compute document vectors,
compute our inner product.
So this is what we want to do.
And document distance 1 does
it in a painfully slow way,
and we're probably not going to
cover everything in recitation.
But if you go all the way
up to document distance 1,
that's really, really fast.
It's 1,000 times faster.
So this is our job for the day.
Let's look at the code.
Did anyone look at
the code beforehand?
Nope.
OK, so when I look at
a big piece of code,
I like to look at
it from top down.
So that means I start
to the main function,
I see who is it calling,
I see what everything
is trying to do, and then
I go into the sub functions
and recurves and basically
do the same thing.
So I build a tree of
who's calling what,
and that helps me figure
out what's going on.
So let's start with main.
And let's look at main.
Lines 1 through 6
look at the arguments.
We don't really care.
Line 7 and 8 call word
frequencies for file.
I am abbreviating liberally.
And then line 9
calls vector angle.
So line 7 and 8 read
the two documents,
do steps one and two, and
then 9 does step three.
OK.
Word frequencies for files.
So the point of this
is to read a file
and to produce a word
document vector out of it.
And it does it in three steps.
Reads the file, line two.
Breaks up the file into
words, so operation one,
this is line 3, and then line
4, it takes up the list of words
and computes a document
vector out of it.
I don't care about
reading files because I'll
assume this is
somehow done for me.
We care about the algorithms.
So as far as I'm
concerned, this function
is calling get words
from line list.
Get words from line list,
and count frequency.
And if we skip all the
way to vector angle--
we already talked a little
bit about how all it does
is it calls inner
product three times
and then in does some
fancy math of it.
So this is how the code
looks like big picture.
OK, so to figure out the
running time for main,
we need to figure out the
running time for these two
functions and add
them up, right?
To figure out the
running time for this,
we need to figure
out the running
time for these functions and
add them up, so on and so forth.
So as you go through each of
the document distance versions,
you want keep a scorecard of the
implementation that shows you
what the running
time is, and this
helps you follow
what was improved
in each implementation.
So let's look at to get
words from line lists.
What does it seem
like its doing?
Without reading the
get words from string,
can anyone tell me what
it seems like it's doing?
If you just read
lines 1 through 6.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
through the list.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
So it's getting an input list.
And if you look at word
frequencies for files
at line 2, it names
a variable line list.
So it seems like
what's happening is,
reads a file into
a list of lines.
And then that list of lines goes
to get words from line lists.
So this is L in get
words from line lists.
So it takes a list of lines
which is the entire document,
and then?
AUDIENCE: Basically it
removes the new lines.
It sticks it into one giant list
rather than a list of lines,
is that right?
VICTOR COSTAN: Almost, so you
seem to get words from string.
Maybe we need to go
through the function,
but do see the get words
from string function name?
So I will assume that
it does something
with each of the words.
And if the overall goal
is to get a list of words,
then I would assume that what
that does is it takes a line
and it breaks it up into words.
Because this way, if
you take up each line
and break it up into
words, then when
we put all the words
together we get the words
that make up the document.
Do people follow?
Any questions?
I like that people are nodding,
by the way, keep doing that.
That helps me go
at the right speed.
If you're not nodding, I'll
keep explaining the same thing
over and over again.
OK, so get words from string.
Get words from string takes up
a single line, that's a string,
and produces a list of words.
And we saw in the
example there that it
has to take care of a few
details such as making
all the letters
lowercase and ignoring
punctuation and skipping spaces.
So let's look at this code and
figure out its running time.
And the way we're going
to do that is we're
going to look at
each line, and we're
going to see what's
the cost for that line
and how many times does it run.
And once we have
those two numbers,
we multiply them together
and we see how much time
does the program spend
on that line in total.
So I'm going to write
down line numbers here.
9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15.
All the way to 23.
Too low.
20, 21, 22, 23.
OK, so let's start
with something easy,
lines 9 and 10 How many
times are they run?
AUDIENCE: Once.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Once in this method?
VICTOR COSTAN: Yep.
So I'm only looking
at this method.
So assuming that the method
gets one line, and the line has,
I don't know, say, one
line in characters,
and we need another
variable which
we're going to figure out later.
But for now, one
line in characters.
So how many times
does line 9 run?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
Runs once.
How about line 10?
AUDIENCE: Once.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
What do they do?
Create new lists and
assign them to variables.
What's the cause for that?
AUDIENCE: Constant [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN:
Constant, excellent.
So I'll be skipping
the order of so
that I don't have to
write it 23 times.
So 1, 1.
OK, line 11.
It's iterates over all
the characters in a line.
So how many times
is it going to run?
AUDIENCE: Like, the line?
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, which is?
AUDIENCE: Line end characters.
VICTOR COSTAN: Awesome.
And just the fact of
iterating takes constant time.
I'm not sure we covered that.
So for each character, test if
it's an alphanumeric character.
Does anyone know what
alphanumeric means?
AUDIENCE: It's a
letter and a number.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, so fancy
word for letter or number,
A through Z, 0 through 9.
So how much time
does it take to test
if a character is alphanumeric?
Guesses?
AUDIENCE: Constant.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK,
so constant time.
You compare it to the
range A, Z and 0, 9.
How many times am I doing it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN:
Thank you guys, this
is going much faster
than the last recitation.
You guys are active, I like it.
So, now for line 13.
That only gets executed
when the character
is an alphanumeric character.
So we're going to have
to make some assumptions
about the document.
And to make my
life easier, we're
going to make the
following assumption.
If this is a natural
language like, say, English,
words are going to be
a constant size, right?
How many 500-character
words do you see in English?
So let's say 5 to 10
characters per word.
And since the
difference is so small,
I'm going to say all the
words have the same size
W. And if you want
to be more formal,
you can replace word
length with average length,
and the math works out.
So each line has
a number of words,
and the words are separated
by exactly one space,
and the word has W characters.
So how many words do
I have, by the way?
AUDIENCE: N divided by W.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, good.
Someone's paying
close attention.
N divided by W plus 1.
And the reason
that is, is a line
would look like this, word,
space, word, space, word,
space.
So W, characters, one space,
W, characters, one space, W,
characters, one space.
That's why you have
W plus 1 there.
When we look at
asymptotics it turns out
that it doesn't really matter
because W's a constant,
W plus 1 is a constant,
so order and words.
But for now, let's keep track of
W's to seem a bit more formal.
So line 13.
How many times is
it going to run?
AUDIENCE: W times
10 over W plus one.
VICTOR COSTAN: Excellent.
Let me pull them out.
How much time does it
take to run [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Constant?
VICTOR COSTAN:
Constant time, append,
covered in lecture,
constant time.
So this is a bit tricky
because if you have an array
implementation that's naive,
it's not constant time.
But Python does some magic
called table doubling, which
we'll cover later in the course.
And this is why you can say
that append takes constant time.
OK.
Else, so if the character
is not alphanumeric,
than what's going on here?
Can anyone see what's
happening there?
AUDIENCE: If its
like, [INAUDIBLE].
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, so
let's say if it's a space.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: Yeah,
this the harder part.
I think you need to
run this on an example
to figure out what's going on.
I have to run it on
an example in my head.
So let's take this small example
here, the fox is outside.
And this is a
single line, right?
Nice and handy.
So this can be the input
for get words from string.
And let's see what happens.
So first I start with word list
which is empty list, character,
lists, empty list.
Take the first character,
it's alphanumeric,
gets appended here, the second
character, alphanumeric,
appended here, third
gets appended here.
Fourth character,
not alphanumeric,
so I get to run
lines 15 through 18.
OK, I did the easy part.
Someone walk me
through the hard part.
What happens in
lines 15 through 18?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: First, it takes
that list and joins it
into a string. [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, so this
is a list of characters.
And join takes the list and
makes a string out of it.
So I'll have the string the.
OK, excellent.
AUDIENCE: And it converts
it all to lower case.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: End up [INAUDIBLE]
that to the word list.
VICTOR COSTAN: The world
list is up here, right?
So this is going to have the.
AUDIENCE: And then it clears
the character list, [INAUDIBLE].
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
So now as I go through the
next word, I have F-O-X.
Then this becomes the word,
and it gets added here.
So on and so forth
for everything.
Do people see how
this method works now?
I'm not getting that
many nods, so questions.
If I don't get nods,
I'll stop and you guys
have to ask what
you're confused about.
AUDIENCE: I think it's a
little tricky because instead
of saying if it's not an
alphanumeric character,
it's just like well, if
the length of the list
is greater than 0, which
threw me off initially,
but then I realized it
was just, like, omission.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, so
why does it do this?
What is the point of the
length of the character list?
AUDIENCE: So that
there are two spaces.
VICTOR COSTAN: Excellent.
So here I was nice and I had
one space, one space, one space.
But if I'm sloppy when I'm
typing and I have two spaces
here, then suppose this is
space, space-- kind a small,
but pretend.
Go with me here.
So we got here.
We got the fox is.
And then this list is
empty because line 18 just
made it empty.
If I run the code the
lines 15 through 18,
it's going to add an
empty word up here.
And empty words
aren't very useful.
You'll see how many
times the documents have
too many spaces in them, so
that doesn't really help.
AUDIENCE: I mean, isn't
that not an issue,
because you call if C is
L1 before you actually
get to that.
So you'd run through it
again, but you would still
just skip over that.
That would fail, I
mean it would not
do anything for that equation.
VICTOR COSTAN: So first space.
C as L now fails.
I run lines 15 through 18.
AUDIENCE: Yep.
VICTOR COSTAN: Right?
I have is here.
This becomes empty.
AUDIENCE: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Second space,
C as L now fails again.
AUDIENCE: Yep.
VICTOR COSTAN: And if I
wouldn't have the length check,
it would run lines
15 through 18 again.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, so this is
what it's trying to prevent.
So you can see that this code
looks complicated, right?
It's trying to do a lot of
things, it's complicated,
it's hard to analyze.
Oh, well, let's go with it.
Let's try to finish
it up quickly.
So now that we know
what it does, let's
try to figure out how
many times each line runs
and what's the cost?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I think the
total cost is N times 1
minus W over W plus 1.
VICTOR COSTAN: Wait, so here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, so you're
saying N times 1 minus.
OK.
Why do you say that?
I like it, but why?
OK, it's because it's everything
that is in the character,
and the line above
it was characters--
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: --all
alphanumeric, [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: So
basically spaces, right?
If we have word, space,
word, space, word, space,
this happens for all the spaces.
Cool.
So this is good.
I'm going to make
it a bit simpler.
Same thing, it's just that it's
slightly less intimidating.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
VICTOR COSTAN: Cool, thank you.
Very brave, come up first.
What's the running
time for line 14?
So, cost for running it once.
AUDIENCE: Constant.
Excellent.
VICTOR COSTAN: I like you guys.
Nice.
Line 15, how much
time does it to take
to take characters and
put them into a list?
AUDIENCE: N?
VICTOR COSTAN: N--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: --where N is
the size of the list, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
So what's the size
of the list now?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: Yep.
OK, so when you're using
more than one letter,
the problem is you have to
pay attention to which one
you're using.
Because when we
teach algorithms,
we say oh, this is N, this is
N squared, so on and so forth.
You have to replace it
to the right letter.
And I get confused about
this all the time, so--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: --a
serious problem.
AUDIENCE: --columns?
What are the two columns?
VICTOR COSTAN: So this is the
cost of running a line once,
and this is how
many times it's run.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
VICTOR COSTAN: Thanks
for the question.
I should have said
that in the beginning.
Thank you.
OK, let's make this
a little bit faster
and notice that
lines 15 through 18
all run the same
number of times, right?
They're in the if, and
there's nothing else
that's changes the
control flow there.
So lines 15 through 18 are
O and divided by W plus 1.
All right, line 16.
Take a word.
So take a string and
make another string
where each character is
the lowercase version.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, cool.
Why W, intuitively?
AUDIENCE: Because [INAUDIBLE]
has to check to make sure
[INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: Yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: Yeah, so if
you have a 10,000 character
string you, have to go
through 10,000 characters.
Very good.
Append 917.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: Sweet.
And line 18, we said the
character list of length list.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: [INAUDIBLE]
OK, how many times
do lines 19 through 23 run?
AUDIENCE: Once.
VICTOR COSTAN: At most, once.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: Can anyone figure
out what's the point of them?
AUDIENCE: Catch any
trailing [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: Good.
If you ended on the
last letter of a word,
you want to make sure
you catch that word.
VICTOR COSTAN: All right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: Very good.
So I find it here.
Then after I'm done
with the loop at line 19
what the word list
would have, the fox is.
And then the
character list would
have the characters for outside.
If I return the word list,
woops, I just missed a word.
So lines 20 through 22 are a
copy of lines 15 through 17,
and they take care
of the last word.
So line 19 is an if, and it
takes the length of a list
and compares it to the number.
What's the cost of that?
AUDIENCE: Constant.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, very good.
Checking list length in
Python is constant time.
We did that in lecture.
How about lines 20 through 22?
I just gave it
away, guys, come on.
Someone--
AUDIENCE: The same
as 15 through 17.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK,
same as 15 through 17.
W, W, 1.
Line 23, return constant time.
OK, so now we know how much
it takes to run a line once,
how many times each line runs.
So we're going to do a
dot product of these guys.
See, dot products are useful.
And if we do a dot
product of these guys,
we're going to get the total
running time for the function.
So let's compute
the partial terms.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: I'm not
going to write them down.
Let's just go through them
and figure out what they are.
So you guys say them.
AUDIENCE: 1, 1, N,
N, weird equation--
VICTOR COSTAN: OK,
weird equation,
what was the important part?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
VICTOR COSTAN: Yeah,
the important part.
The important part is N, right?
This is some constant
times N, so N.
AUDIENCE: N, N,
N, N, N, N, 1, 1.
VICTOR COSTAN: Pay attention.
AUDIENCE: 1, N.
It's not N, it's not 1.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: OK,
actually is 1 I guess,
if you think that
W is a constant.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: You're testing us.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
1, 1.
VICTOR COSTAN: So I heard
two numbers, N and 1, right?
So this is 0 of N plus
1, which is order N,
because as N goes to infinity,
1 becomes really tiny.
OK, so this is how you
analyze a function.
Big functions are horribly
painful to analyze because you
have to look at each line and
do this kind of reasoning.
And it's not even a top
level function here,
so I don't even get to
write anything here yet.
So get words from string
takes order and time
where N is the length of a line.
Let's look at get
words from line list.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
VICTOR COSTAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
is W characters long?
Like, does it matter
if the [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: Does it matter--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] make
that assumption of that?
VICTOR COSTAN: So that I can
reason for lines 15 and 16.
I can reason through them easily
if I have a content length.
It turns out that if you
have an average length,
the results are
going to be the same.
Like overall, if you look at the
running time as a sum of what's
the running time for converting
all the words to lowercase
and then appending
them to the list.
The sum of those is
still going to be n N,
but that takes a bit more
time to reason through
so I took a shortcut.
Are you a math
major, by the way?
You're very rigorous.
OK.
So this is good, it's
always good to try
to keep this in the
back of your head
to make sure you
don't fall for a trap.
So get words from
string order N,
and we're trying to figure
out get words from line list.
Any more questions
before I do that?
Or does anyone want
to tell me I'm wrong?
OK, good.
So get words from line list.
Lines 2 through 6.
2 3, 4, 5, 6.
Line 2.
AUDIENCE: 1.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, cost 1,
how many times does it run?
AUDIENCE: Once.
VICTOR COSTAN: Cool.
Line 3.
We need a new number, right?
We need the number of
lines in a document.
Let's say we have Z lines.
So line 3 runs Z times,
and 4 and 5 are in a loop
so they also run Z times
What's the cost for line 4?
AUDIENCE: 1.
VICTOR COSTAN: Excellent.
What's the cost for line 3?
AUDIENCE: 1.
VICTOR COSTAN: 1.
And what is the cost for line 5?
AUDIENCE: Looks constant.
VICTOR COSTAN:
Looks constant, OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: Does anyone
else think it looks constant?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's a trap.
VICTOR COSTAN: It's a trap.
It's a trap.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: --length
of the two lists.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
Good.
You paid attention
in lecture, right?
AUDIENCE: I try.
VICTOR COSTAN: Nice.
OK, so we have plus
as an operator,
and suppose we work
with two lists.
The first list is 1, 2, 3,
all the way through 1,000.
And the second list is 1, 2, 3.
So when you code
plus to combine them,
if you say something
like C equals A plus B,
you would expect that--
if this is A, by the way
and this is B-- you would expect
that after you call this A is
still this, B is
still this, and C
is a list that
contains everything.
So because of that, what plus
has to do is make a new list,
append all the elements here,
append all the elements here.
So the cost of this if this
list is 1,000 and this list is 3
is 1,003.
Or if you have two lists
of length, L1 and L2
the cost is order of L1 plus L2.
Now there's another Python
method called extend,
which does what I think
you would expect plus
to do in terms of efficiency.
So what extend does is you
call it a 1 or A on one list,
give it the other
list, and it's going
to take each element
in the second list
and append it to the first list.
So for each element here, it
calls append on this list.
So what's the running
time for extend?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, there are
too many directions and--
AUDIENCE: Length
of the second list.
VICTOR COSTAN: Length of
the second list, excellent.
So two lists, L1,
L2, order of L2.
So it doesn't matter
this is 1,000 elements
are a million elements,
appending three elements is
going to take time
proportional to three.
OK now, let's see
what's going on here.
So we have Z lines and
characters in a line.
I think I want a nicer constant.
No, let's go with this for now.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] lines.
VICTOR COSTAN: So this
is the length of a word.
Let's see, how many words
will I have in a line?
Let's say I have K words in a
line, which is N divided by W.
So I know that to
get words from string
returns a list of size K.
So if that is the case, then
the first time line 5
runs, word list is empty.
And it's going to
get K elements.
The second time it runs,
word list has K elements
and gets K more.
Third time, it has 2K
elements, it gets K more.
So the running time for
this looks like this.
K plus 2K plus 3K
plus 4K all the way
until when I'm at the last
line, if I have Z lines.
I had Z minus 1 times
K elements in the list,
because I have Z minus 1
lines and I put all the words
in the list, and I'm
adding K more words.
So total, Z times
K running time.
So this is the total
running time for this guy.
And this is not constant,
so it's complicated.
What is the sum come
down to, asymptotically?
AUDIENCE: Z plus
1K times Z over 2.
VICTOR COSTAN: Ok.
Z plus 1K, ZK over 2.
Slow because I care
about asymptotics,
this is order of Z
squared times K, right?
So now any one more
natural number to work with
would be the number of
words in a document.
And the number of
words in a document
is W, which is Z times K.
So Z is W divided by K.
And if I substitute
this, I get that this
is equal to 0 of W squared over
K. Now in a reasonable document
that I see, there tends to
be a limited number of words
per line because the document
has to fit on a page.
So K's pretty much a constant.
So this comes down to
order of W squared.
So if I go down here and look
at get word from line list,
this is W squared, where
W is how many words I
have in a document.
How many of you guys
are still with me?
Half.
OK.
Does anyone else want
to ask questions,
so that you can
get back on track?
Yes, no?
AUDIENCE: It makes sense so far.
VICTOR COSTAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I think
I didn't understand
the part of [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
Thank you.
So let's see what's going
on lines 2 through 5.
So I have a word list, which
at the beginning is empty.
Then in line 4, words
in line gets K words.
And those K words in line
five are added to word list.
So after that, word
list has K words.
Then I run through
the loop again.
Get the words from string
gives me K new words.
They get added to the list,
which now has 2K words.
Next time I get K
more words, they
get that added to the
list, which has 3K.
So on and so forth
until the end.
I have ugly numbers.
Z minus 1 times K words
and I add the last K words.
I'm getting confused here.
And I get Z times K words.
So the word list is eventually
going to have Z times K words,
and it gets them K at a time.
The thing that does this
addition is the plus operator.
And the running time
for the plus operator
is the size of the two lists,
so it's this plus this.
So that's why the running time
is first K, then 2K, then 3K,
then-- make sense now?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
So this is a subtle bug because
if you change plus to extend,
you get [? bug ?] disk two,
which runs a lot faster.
OK.
So for everything
else, we want to be
able to do this
sort of analysis,
but we want to do it faster.
So you guys should look
through [? bug list ?] one
through eight and do the same
analysis for all the functions.
And we're going to post
recitation notes where
we tell you this is the
function that changed,
and this is the
total running time.
And you should go
through the lines
and convince yourself that
this is the right running time.
And you should do that until
it becomes second nature,
because when you're
writing Python code,
you want to have
this in your head.
You don't want to
have to write it down,
because if you have to write it
down, you're going to be lazy
and you're not going
to do it, and you're
going to use plus
instead of extend,
and your code is going
to be horribly slow.
So practice until this
gets in your head,
and then you'll be able to see
the running time for things
really quickly.
OK, do we have time for
once more let me see.
OK.
Let's look at the running
time for inner products,
because this is nice and easy.
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
2 is 1, 1, very nice and easy.
3 looks at the first document
list and iterates through it.
Iteration is constant time, but
if the first document vector
has L1 elements, it's
going to run L1 times.
How about line 4,
words 2 count 2 in L2.
This is iteration again, so it's
constant time to run it once,
but how many times will it run?
AUDIENCE: L2 times L1 times.
VICTOR COSTAN: L2
times the 1, excellent.
So these two loops are
nested inside each other
so that means that
lines 4 through 6
are going to run once
every time line 3 iterates.
So sorry, actually
line 4 is going
to run once every
time line 3 iterates.
And then everything
inside the second 4
is going to run
L1 times L2 times.
So lines 5 and 6 are also
going to run L1, L2 times.
L1, L2, L1, L2.
How much time does it take
to do that if check there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: Why does
it take a constant time?
AUDIENCE: I was going to
say, it wasn't constant,
so you don't have to pair
each character with no word.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, good.
So we have two words,
and equal, equal
tells me are the words
equal or not, right?
So the way you do that, is you
have words like the and fox.
You go through each
character, and you
stop whenever you see
different characters.
But if you have something
like, if you have a fake word
F-O-I and fox, then go
through the first character,
they're equal, second character,
they're equal, third character,
they're different.
So if you have
length W words that
are different only in
the last character,
this is going to
be order W, right?
So the real--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: --yep, equals,
equals 4 strings not constant.
It takes W time where W
is the length of a word.
Now here we said that
the length of a word
is constant because we're
dealing with English.
So you could tell me it is
constant because of that.
But I would like to hear the
argument before I take it.
How about line 6?
AUDIENCE: Well,
if the plus equals
is going to be the same
thing before when we were,
every new time your
plus equals, so it's
going to be like how the word
list before we were adding it,
where we have to
create that object,
and then add it to the length.
I mean, its going
to be length of sum.
Sorry.
And then you add in the new one.
So every time its going
to be increasing, correct?
VICTOR COSTAN: Almost.
It's a trap again.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
VICTOR COSTAN: Yep.
Yeah, so this time
they're not lists.
So if you look at what's
going on inside there,
you have count one
and count two are
these numbers in the document
vector, so they're numbers.
And then some starts
out at 0, and then it
keeps getting numbers.
So sum is going to be a number.
And multiplying numbers
is constant time,
adding numbers is constant
time, so plus for numbers
is order 1 indeed.
AUDIENCE: You're
reassigning sum every time?
VICTOR COSTAN: Which
is also constant.
AUDIENCE: OK.
VICTOR COSTAN: Because
you're copying a number over.
So as long as you're
copying one element over,
that's constant time.
If you're adding two elements
together-- two elements,
not two lists--
that's constant time.
So this is constant.
And the last line is returned.
So what's the running
time for this?
AUDIENCE: L2 times L1.
VICTOR COSTAN: Excellent.
So I assume this is a constant.
So this lets me say
this is 1, and then
if we do the partial products
we get 1L, 1L, 1, and L2.
L1, L2, L1, L2.
And if you add them
up, you get L1 and L2.
So this is going to be L1, L2.
Vector angle calls inner
product three times, right?
So what's it's running time?
AUDIENCE: L1, L2.
VICTOR COSTAN: Excellent.
Count frequency.
You're going to have
to take my word for it
that this is order of W squared.
And if that's the case,
what's the running
time for a word
frequency for file?
AUDIENCE: W squared?
VICTOR COSTAN: Cool.
So.
What's the running
time for main now?
Last trick.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: Yep, If
you just add them up,
except there is one
last trick there.
AUDIENCE: If W is
constant, [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: No.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
W's constant, right?
VICTOR COSTAN: No.
So W is the number of
words in a document.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
VICTOR COSTAN: So it's huge.
If that's constant,
then the whole problem
should run in order one
time, and we're done.
We're going home.
AUDIENCE: W squared because
it beats out L1 and L2.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, so--
AUDIENCE: L1--
VICTOR COSTAN: --you're
going faster than me.
You're going too fast,
but you're right.
So word frequency for
file is called twice.
The first document is
going to have W1 words.
The second document is
going to have W2 words.
So you can just copy W
because this is called twice
for different files.
So this is order of
W1 squared plus W2
squared, different documents.
And then I have plus L1, L2.
And you said that W1 and W2
dominate L1 and L2, right?
Because W's the total number
of words in a document,
whereas L the is the
number of unique words,
because it the
length of the vector.
So that is true,
but I'm not sure
how to reduce this here
to make use of that.
However, I made use of what you
said already when I wrote this.
You see why?
Can anyone else see why?
So let's look at the vector
angle again, lines 2 and 3.
So line 2, it calls inner
product with L1 and L2.
But if you look at line
3, it calls inner product
with L1, L1 and then L2, L2
So the total running time
for vector angle is
actually L1, L2 plus L1
squared plus L2 squared.
So if the first
document has 1,000 words
and the second
document as one word,
computing the inner
product between L1 and L1
is going to take a lot
more time than computing
the inner product
between L1 and L2.
So I can't leave
out these terms.
They have to be here.
However, when I
add them up here--
if I would write W1 squared
plus W2 squared plus L1 squared
plus L2 squared plus
this-- in that case,
I can use the fact that
W1 is bigger than L1,
and it cancels it out.
Does this make sense?
Did I lose people?
Ask questions, please.
AUDIENCE: But you can't
get rid of L1 and L2
and not an [INAUDIBLE].
VICTOR COSTAN: You can't--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: Oh, so I
can't get rid of this term--
AUDIENCE: --those, right?
So this should be the sum
of this and this, right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
VICTOR COSTAN: So it should
be W1 squared plus W2 squared
plus L1 squared plus
L2 squared plus L1, L2.
AUDIENCE: Right.
L1 is strictly smaller than W1.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Goes away, L2 smaller than
W2 goes away, and I get this.
Correct.
So L1L2 isn't smaller than
W [INAUDIBLE] squared?
VICTOR COSTAN: Is it?
If you know more
math than me, you
might be able to
prove that it is,
but I don't, so I'm just
leaving it in there.
AUDIENCE: Ok.
VICTOR COSTAN: Yeah.
I think there is some
relation, but I really
don't remember what
it this, so let's
leave it like that for now.
Yeah, I think it should
be the case that these
are bigger than this,
but I'm not sure.
OK, yes.
AUDIENCE: How do you get
the line for vector angle?
VICTOR COSTAN: How do I get
the running time for it?
So vector angle gets
two vectors, right?
The vector for document one and
the vector for document two.
The length of the
first vector is L1.
second vector is L2.
Now, line, where is it?
Line 2, for numerator calls
inner product with L1 and L2.
So we know that the running
time is L1, L2 up here.
Now the next line,
line 3 in vector angle,
calls inner product
with L1 and L1.
So the running time is L1
times L1 which is L1 squared.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Can we say
that because there's
a bounded number of words in the
English language, L1's bounded?
And as the length
of the document
gets really, really big,
that [INAUDIBLE] constant?
VICTOR COSTAN: Yeah, you
might be able to do that.
Yes, I think for the cases
that we give you, that is true.
Yeah, I never thought
of that, that's cool.
AUDIENCE: It doesn't work if
it's not a language, right?
If you just have gibberish?
VICTOR COSTAN: Yes, also, to
say that its constant is useful
when the number of
words in English
is much smaller than
your input size.
So if, say, English
has 50,000 words
and your input is 3,000 words,
then the input is much smaller.
But if you're input is
a million words, which
I think is what
we use, then yeah,
it comes down to constant.
So yeah, that's a good insight.
That's really nice.
Anything else?
OK, so you get to go through
document distance 3 to 8.
We'll tell you what's
changed, and we'll
give you a chance to
help you analyze it.
But you have to analyze it,
then update the scorecard
for each algorithm to
see how things improve.
Thanks.